everybody's Gary Vaynerchuk and I'm
sorry I'm a mess I look all remind I'm
sorry I just got into Houston again I've
taken a four or five flights at five
o'clock in the morning the last couple
days and then again tomorrow as I go to
Chicago for seed conference hanging out
with coudl and Jason free even those
guys so looking forward to anybody I see
in Chicago but what I want to talk about
today on Gary on intercom is community a
lot of people over the last 3-4 days
I've been running into a lot of tech
keeps saying when do you know that you
have a community and this has really
hurt my feelings
I don't know why nobody's figured us out
but you have a community when one person
listens to you community communication
you're communicating to somebody and as
long as you have one person to talk to
you have a community and I think way too
many people are looking at how many
Twitter followers to have or how many
RSS people they're having following them
and that's a mistake guys you need to
embrace your community no matter how big
or small I mean everybody started off
real real small I mean why not be TV had
five ten fifteen viewers at first and
you know what I did I answered every
single comment not just emails I got but
if somebody left a comment I kept in an
answered every single one of those of
course I can't do that anymore but you
know what in the beginning those are the
glorious days my friend I missed the
days of when my community was much
smaller because it was extremely
intimate and those are amazing times and
so stop worrying about the stats and the
numbers and oh I don't want to do a
video every day nobody's listening
anyway stop crying and stop embracing
the fact you have somebody who cares
about what you say having one viewer
watch a video or one reader listen to a
or excuse me
read a blog post is an amazing feat and
something that should be embraced and
I'm just so sick and tired of all these
people not embracing and realizing how
lucky they are that anybody cares about
what's going through their beautiful
little brain and so I wanted to make
this video and I hope a lot of people
pass this on because I think the
majority of the people in social media
right now need to listen to this message
and hopes other people can add to this
conversation because when way way way
too many people are taking for granted
the lovely people that are following
them and I just will never do that and
I've got a lot more
land and it's very flattering so I thank
everybody which everyone of you and I
hope you think each and every one of
your community members